اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في حصاد الليله معكم
حسن جم
وفي الوقت الذي يحدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى
هذه الصور من نيامي عاصمه النيجر وهناك
ترقب على اكثر من صعيد قرار طرد السفير
الفرنسي وتاهب ضد التدخل عسكري محتمل فيما
شهدت المدينه التظاهره الاكبر ضد وجود
القاعده الفرنسيه
وهذه الصور من ولايه فلوريدا وكلمه للرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن من هناك بعد الاعصار
الذي ضرب الولايه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
القوات الروسيه تعلن التصدي لمسيرات بحريه
استهدفت جسر القرم وبعد حديث عن تقدمها في
زابولوجيا القوات الاوكرانيه تكثف هجماتها
نحو مدينه من الطبول جنوبا
وترقب لتزويد واشنطن لقياد بقذائف تحتوي
على اليورانيوم المنظم
في خطوه اضافيه نحو طرد السفير الفرنسي
المحكمه العليا في النيجر تصدق على قرار
ترحيله مظاهرات امام قاعده القوات
الفرنسيه في ميامي للمطالبه برحيلها وقاده
الانقلاب يدعون الى التاهب للتصدي لاي
تدخل عسكري محتمل
اصابه نحو 170 شخصا خلال اشتباكات بين
طالبي لجوء اريتيريين في تل ابي
ب الشرطه الاسرائيليه والانصابه نحو 30 من
قواتها في الصدمات وحكومه نتنياهو تشكل
طريقا خاصا باتخاذ اجراءات ضد المشاركين
بما في ذلك الترحيل
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا تداعيات تصريحات وزيره
التعاون والتنميه الدلجيكيه كارولينز عن
انتهاكات اسرائيل بحق الفلسطينيين والتي
احدثت ازمه دبلوماسيه مع اسرائيل
التصريحات تضمنت اشاره لقتل الاطفال
الفلسطينيين ومسح قرى بكاملها من الخريطه
وتدمير مدارس واحياء مموله من الاتحاد
الاوروبي
لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي في اي سياق
تاتي انتقادات الوزيره البلجيكيه لممارسات
اسرائيل ضد الفلسطينيين النتائج جاءت على
شكل التالي
36% ارجع ذلك الى انتقاد غربي عام لسياسه
اسرائيل بينما اعتبر 64% ان هذه
الانتقادات مرتبطه بحكومه نتنياهو حصرا
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصه الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
نظره من التخوم اطلاله خاصه للجزيره على
علاقات روسيا التاريخيه ببعض الدول
الاوروبيه اثر الحرب في اوكرانيا
والبدايه من فنلندا
قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان الجيش
الاوكراني يواصل هجماته باستخدام
المروحيات والطائرات في اتجاه مدينه
ميليتو بول من محاور عده في الجبهه
الجنوبيه في زابولوجيا في هذه الاثناء
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه التصديه لهجوم
اوكراني بثلاثه زوارق مسيره استهدفت جسر
القرن خلال ساعات الماضيه ياتي ذلك بينما
تحدثت وسائل اعلام اوكرانيه عن قرب تزويد
واشنطن لكياز بذخائر مدفعيه تحتوي على
يورانيوم منظم يمكن استخدامها في مدفع
دبابات ابرامز الامريكيه
ثمه متغيرات يمكن رستها من واقع واخبار
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا تزخم الهجمات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه بدا صوته اعلى خصوصا
في الجبهه الجنوبيه يتحدث الرئيس
الاوكراني عن تقدم لقوته على جبهات القتال
فيؤكد منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه بمجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي
قائلا ان الامر حقيقه ماثله خصوصا منذ
ثلاثه ايام متوقعا ردا روسيا على التقدم
الاوكراني الاخير
لعل ابرز معالمه تركيز القوات الاوكرانيه
تقدمها باستخدام المروحيه والطائرات في
اتجاه مدينه ميلوتوبول من محاور عده حيث
تقابل برد روسي لمنع التقدم الاوكراني
باتجاه عمق دفاعاتها تحاول القوات
الاوكرانيه في هجومها المضاد الوصول الى
بحر ازوف لقطع الطريق بين القرم والجبه
الشرقيه بينما استعدت القوات الروسيه لذلك
بخطوط دفاعيه متعدده وياتي هذا عقب تقدم
حققه الاوكرانيون قبل ايام على محور
اوريخوف وانتهى الى اختراق الدفاعات
القوات الروسيه في الجنوب واستعاده بلده
روبوتينو جنوب زبوروجيا التركيز الاوكراني
على هذا المحور يبدو انه يحاول الاستفاده
من استراتيجيه ارباك تنتهجها كييف خصوصا
بهجمات الطائرات المسيره وحتى المسيرات
البحريه التي توسعت واضحت موسكو ومدن
حدوديه روسيه مسرحا لها فضلا عن جسر القرم
هذا الاخير وفقه وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
تعرض لهجوم اوكراني بثلاثه زوارق مسيره تم
صده وهو الذي تعرض للاستهداف مرتين على
الاقل هذا العام جبهه اخرى لا تقل اهميتها
حيث تحدثت الاركان الاوكرانيه عن صديقوتها
هجمات روسيه مركزه في جبهه كوبيانسكيف حيث
تحاول القوه الروسيه التقدم باتجاهها منذ
اسابيع وبالمقابل في دونيات تصعيد وفق
السلطاتها المواليه لروسيا مع دفع القوات
الاوكر بمزيد من التعزيزات نحو خطوط
التماس في مناطق ستار مايورسك واوروغيني
وحديثها عن نحو 70 هجوما اوكرانيا في يوم
واحد على
استادف مناطق عديده في المدينه فضلا عن
مدنوفكا
بدورها والتي كانت بعيده نسبيا عن تطور
الجبهات ظهر اسمها مره اخرى ببث
الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه صورا قالت انها
الاستهداف اليات لوحده دفاع جويه روسيه
نفذتها وحده اوميجا الخاصه وذلك بواسطه
مسيرات قرب مدينه
عن تزويدها من قبل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه قريبا بدخائر مدفعيه تحتوي على
اليورانيوم المنظم يمكن استخدامها في مدفع
دبابات ابرامز الامريكيه سيتم ذلك خلال
الاسابيع حيث تعد ذخائر المدفعيه هذه من
الاشد فتكا بالدروع لاسيما انها قادره على
اختراقها وتدميرها واثر استخدامها جدلا
وتحذيرا كبيرا من روسيا
هجمات اوكرانيه بالمسيرات وتقدم على محاور
وتعزيز روسي لمواقع على طول خط المواجهه
هي جبهه ملتهبه وتزداد التهابا تكشف تغير
اولويات وحسابه اطراف الحرب فتقدم هنا
تقابله خساره هناك
ينضم الى هنا من موسكو بافل فيلين هاور
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي كما ينضم
الينا من كيات بيتر زلميذ المحلل في شؤون
السياسيه والعسكريه ادى معك السيد بافلجن
هاور
الى اي مدى
سيؤثر تزويد كياف
بذخائر مدفعيه تحتوي يورانيوم منظم على
القوات الروسيه في ساحه المعركه
الجنوب بشكل مكثف
لان دبابات ابرامزه لم تصل بعد وابرادي
ربما قد تستخدم لكن هنالك اسلحه اخرى
بالتالي كما قلت ستكون فعاله لكن ليس
فعاليه كبيره في ارض المعركه
هل قررت تزويد غياب
مدفعيه مزوده باليورانيوم منظب هل هذا
القرار تعويض
لاوكرانيا حتى الان عن
عدم تحقيق شيء كبير في الهجوم المضاد اذا
لم نقل تعويض عن فشل هذا الهجوم حتى
اللحظه
بدايه فشل نتحدث عن الفشل الان الفشل هو
ربما يحصل في الاكبر ثاني جيش في العالم
جيش الروسي الذي قال انه يسيطر على كيف
خلال ثلاثه ايام لكنه الان يناضل في
السيطره على باخ موت وهي ربما اكبر انجاز
للجيش الروسي خلال اشهر عديده هذه النقطه
الاولى النقطه الثانيه عندما قال المتحدث
من موسكو انها لن تؤثر بالكثير علينا ان
نقول انها ستحقق فرقا كما الصلاه مع ذقائر
العنقوديه انا اتحدث هنا بخلاف ضيفكم ان
اتحدث مع الجنود بشكل يومي ويتاكدوا لي ان
هذه الذخائر كانت مهمه بالاضافه اضافه
اليها الدبابات وطائرات اف 16 وايضا
التكنولوجيا الاوكرانيه ليس فقط لانتاج
المسيرات والصواريخ التي قد تصل الى
كل هذه الامور ستزيد فعاليه الحرب ضد
فلاتي وستخلق الظروف الملائمه من اجل
تغيير حقيقي داخل روسيا ان النظام الروسي
يبدو وكانه قوي الى ان في لحظه واحده
سينهار
تمرد بريكوشن اظهر انه ليس هنالك دعم كبير
لبلاديمير بوتين ان قوته تعتمد على الخوف
والخوف لوحده هو الاوكرانيون يظهرون انه
ليس هنالك سبب للخوف علينا ان نقاتل الشر
وان
اعود الى السيد بعض
يعني الحديث في موسكو دائما عن فشل
اوكرانيا في هجومها المضاد ولكن لا نسمع
حديثا عن عدم تقدم روسي اساسا يعني وبقاء
القوات الروسيه في مواقعها وانشغال روسيا
بالمسيرات والطائرات وصواريخ الاوكرانيه
التي تصل الى مقاطعه موسكو
سيد
الاستراتيجيه الروسيه الان تتعلق وتؤكدوا
على الصمود والاحتفاظ بالمواقع التي سيطرت
عليها روسيا على امل ان الاوكرانيين وهجمه
الاوكرانيه التي ربما قد تمتد وقد تبدا
عفوا بعد شهر قد ستنتهي بشكل غير واضح
هذا الامر سيؤثر على الروح المعنويه لدى
الجيش الاوكراني وعلى المجتمع الاوكراني
والاهم من ذلك لروسيا هو انه
التحالف الغربي الواسع الذي الذي يدعم
اوكرانيا سيتاثر ايضا اذا ما تمكنت روسيا
من الصمود هنالك امل ان روسيا تستطيع
انهاء هذا الصراع
بحسب شروطها بشكل جزئي على الاقل هذه
النقطه اسمح لي اعود فيها الى ضيفنا من
قياده سيد زلمياد اذا كانت استراتيجيه
موسكو الان هي الصمود
وليس تحقيق التقدم في المقابل الجيش
الاوكراني ما الذي يريد تحقيقه في منطقه
الجنوب تحديدا
باعتبار انه يركز الان على ميلوتوبول
وايضا على منطقه شبه جزيره القرم باختصار
نعم ان
هذه النافذه قد تتضاء قد يكون لك شهر او
شهر ونصف واوكرانيا تريد ان تحقق
ان لا تقم على الاقل اذا لم تستطع قطع
طريق الامدادات الى بحر ايزوف بامكانها
على الاقل هي تريد ان تصل الى حوالي 30 او
50 كيلومتر من كل خطوط الامدادات
اللوجستيه سيكون هذا نجاحا كبيرا للقوات
الاوكرانيه وايضا سيؤثر ويعيق بشكل كبير
الجهود العسكريه الروسيه اذا لم يحصل هذا
الامر قد هذا ممكن وبعد ذلك نعرف ان بوتين
سيعتمد على الغار اصابه الغرب بالاجهاد
وفلاديمير بوتين هو لن يقوم بالتفاوض مع
اوكرانيا وعلى الغرب ان يفهم ان فلاديمير
بوتين هو يريد ان يقضي على اوكرانيا كدوله
مستقله قالت ذلك
حدثتنا من كييف وشكرا للسيد بافلج الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي حدثنا من موسكو
المسيرات التي كانت جزءا من ملف التطورات
في اوكرانيا هي نباتت الشغل الشاغل للقوى
الكبرى عالميا خطط لبناء جيوش اقل عددا
وتكلفه واكثر ذكاء موضوع سنناقشه في فقره
في المتابعه بعد قليل
الى النيجر حيث احتشد الالاف امام القاعده
الفرنسيه للمطالبه بخروجها من البلاد
مطالبين باريس بسحب سفيرها بعد ان اقرت
المحكمه العليا اليوم طرده فورا والغاء
حصانته الدبلوماسيه هذا وقد دعا رئيس
اركان الجيش الذي عينه قاده الانقلاب الى
الاستعداد لحمايه البلاد من تهديدات اكواس
بالتدخل العسكري
رساله جديده من النيجر موجهه نحو فرنسا
على خلفيه انقلاب السادس والعشرين من
يوليو الماضي الالاف تجمع في العاصمه
النيامي محتجين امام القاعده العسكريه
الفرنسيه مطالبين باريس بسحبها فورا هي
ليست المظاهره الاولى من هذا النوع وبهذه
الشعارات المناوة لفرنسا ولكنها الاكبر
والاوسع على الاطلاق
واشتركت في تنظيمها عده جمعيات شعبيه
تساند المجلس العسكري الحاكم ودعت اليها
كذلك حركه الاتحاد لحمايه سياده وكرامه
شعب النيجر المعروف بامن 62 الناشطه منذ
اغسطس العام الماضي وتضم منظمات مجتمع
مدني مناهضه للوجود العسكري الفرنسي في
النيجر وكان قاده الانقلاب قد الغوا بعد
ايام من سيطرتهم على الحكم عدد من
الاتفاقيات العسكريه المبرمه مع فرنسا و
الاتفاقيه تتيح تمركز كتيبه الفرنسيه
قوامها
1500 جندي في النيجر باسم مكافحه الارهاب
والجماعات المتطرفه ولا تعترف فرنسا بذلك
الالغاء ويعتزم المتظاهرون الاعتصام في
مواقع تجمعهم مطالبين بتنفيذ ذلك القرار
ويطالبون ايضا فرنسا بسحب سفيرها من
البلاد واحترام سياده النيجر وكان وزير
الداخليه في الحكومه التي عينها قاده
الانقلاب قد امر قوات الامن بترحيل السفير
الفرنسي من البلاد ويؤكد الامر ان السفير
وزوجته اصبح في وضع غير قانوني وان
اقامتهما وصفتهما الدبلوماسيه ملغتان
رسميا ويتعين وفق الامر على الجهات
المختصه اتخاذ كل التدابير اللازمه
للتنفيذ الفوري امر كانت قد حذرت منه
قياده الاركان الفرنسيه التي قالت انها
مستعده للرد على اي مساس بوجودها العسكري
او الدبلوماسي في هذه الاثناء يترقب
كثيرون وبينها فرنسا الخطوات القادمه
لمجموعه اكواس التي هددت بالتدخل العسكري
واستعاده النظام الدستوري في النيجر رئيس
اركان الجيش الذي عينه قاده الانقلاب دعا
خلال تفقده بعض القوات للاستعداد والتحلي
باليقظه لحمايه البلاد من تلك التهديدات
الواضح ان القاده العسكريين في النيجر
ماضون في تكريس سلطاتهم ويختارون المواجهه
حتى الان تحت عنوان ان البلاد تواجه منذ
سنوات تحديات امنيه في الداخل والخارج
وعبر الحدود وقد حان اوان التعامل معها
معنى من لندن اليكساينز مدير برنامج
افريقي في معهد تشاتا هاوس مرحبا بك سيد
اليكس هل يمكن لقضيه طرد السفير الفرنسي
في نيامي ان تكون شراره تدخل عسكري فرنسي
ضد النيجر
كلها لا اعتقد انه سيكون هنالك تدخل عسكري
فرنسي السياسه الفرنسيه هي
تقوم باتباع سياسه الاكواز بالتالي فرنسا
ستدعم اي قرار يتخذه الاكواز قد يكون
هنالك تقديم ببعض دعم اذا ما كان هنالك
قرار من قبل العسكري لكنهم لن يقوموا باي
دور قيادي يتقدم الاكواس كيف ستنتهي قضيه
السفير الفرنسي قضيه طرد السفير الفرنسي
وايضا موضوع القاعده العسكريه الفرنسيه
التي تتصاعد الاصوات النيجيريه المطالبه
باغفالها
من الواضح ان هذا الوضع صعب على فرنسا هي
لا تعترف
بالمجلس العسكري في نيامي وتشجع المنظمات
الاقليميه من اجل ان تقوم ببدء بعمليات
مفاوضات بالتالي الوضع صعب عليه فيما
يتعلق بسفيرهم هناك انت محق ان فرنسا
لديها قاعده عسكريه ولديها ايضا
قاعده عسكريه ما تزال موجوده في النيجر
لكن نامل ان يكون هنالك اتفاق على مساله
الانتقال والعوده الى الحكم الدستوري هذا
هو جوهر الجهود الفرنسيه تجاه لم يحصل ذلك
وهذا غير متوقع باختصار شديد ماذا او ماذا
ستفعل فرنسا
حاليا
المفاوضات هي
تركز حول فتره الفتره الانتقاليه للمجلس
العسكري قبل ان يقوم الانتقال الى الحكم
الدستوري المجلس العسكري في نيام قد اقترح
فتره ثلاثه سنوات الاكواس اقترحت فتره
ثمانيه اشهر الى سنه بالتالي هذا هو
الموقف الان اعتقد شخصيا انه سيكون هنالك
نوع من
التنازل واذ ان العقوبات
تلحق الكثير من الضرر بالنيجر واعتقد انه
سيتصلون الى الاتفاق في نهايه المطاف ربما
قد يكون امامنا ربما اسابيع او عده اشهر
قبل ان يصلوا الى اتفاق سيبقى معنا لننتقل
الى الغابون هناك اعلنت سلطات العسكريه
التي نفذت الانقلاب مؤخرا اعاده فتح حدود
البلاد البريه والبحريه والجويه اعتبارا
من اليوم السبت وكانت السلطات العسكريه قد
اعلنت من ذ ستيلاء على السلطه صباح
الاربعاء الماضي اغلاق الحدود حتى اشعار
اخر
من جهتها اعربت فعاليات شعبيه ومنظمات
اهليه من بينها ما يعرف بتجمع حكماء
الجابون الذي يضم وزراء ومسؤولين سابقين
عن دعمها لما وصفته بالانتقال السياسي
السلمي الذي باشره الجيش في الجابون واعرب
رئيس التجمع عن رضاه عن الخطوه التي اقدم
عليها الجيش والتي قال انها حررت البلاد
مما سماها الكتيبه الاجنبيه في اشاره
للنفوذ الذي يتمتع به الاجانب خلال حكم
علي بونجو
علم تجمعوا حكماء الجابون ومجلس الاعيان
بسرور بالخطوه الوطنيه التي ادت الى
الامساك بالسلطه من قبل قوات الدفاع
والامن المنضويه تحت لجنه الانتقال واعاده
بناء المؤسسات ويهنئ التجمع والمجلس
نفسيهما بمناسبه تحرير هذه اللجنه الوطنه
من نير بونغو والمحكمه الدستوريه والكتيبه
الاجنبيه ويعربان عن سرورهما ايضا اذ
يلاحظان تحقيق اللجنه انتقالا سياسيا
سلميا دون خسائر في الارواح
نعود الى ضيفنا من لندن اليكس فاينز سيد
اليكس يلاحظ نوع من الازدواجيه في التعامل
مع موضوع الانقلابات في النيجر
التراه فرنسا امر مختلف كليا عن الجابون
لماذا هناك شيء من التسامح مع انقلاب
الجابون وليس هذا التسامح موجودا في
النيجر مثلا
هذا سؤال وجيه ليس كل انقلاب
متشابه هو الانقلاب في الجابوني يتعلق
بالانتخابات غير النزيهه كانت الانتخابات
قد حصلت قبل اسبوع ولم يكن هنالك مراقبون
دوليين ولم يتم الترحيب بمسائل الاعلام
العالميه وكان هنالك حظر تجوال ايضا
بالتالي علينا ان نطرح الاسئله الذي كان
يخاف منه الرئيس او السلطات في ذلك في
الكابون في تلك المرحله بالتالي
السياسه الفرنسيه والسياسه الدوليه تجاه
الغابون ترى العوده الى
نظام الدستوري وهذه هي الرغبه لكن السؤال
هو هل ان نتائج الانتخابات التي حصلت
الاسبوع
الماضي هل سهم قاموا بوجود مرشحين
بالمعارضه اذا ما كان هذا
الوضع فربما هم يجب ان يكونوا حاضرين في
الحكومه الجابون اذا بالنسبه اذا السؤال
الاساسي هو يتعلق بالفتره الانتقاليه في
حاله الغابون يجب ان يكون هل هنالك حاجه
لحصول انتخابات جديده اما ان انتخابات
التي حصلت الاسبوع الماضي والنتائج قامت
بانتخاب المعارضه ام لا شكرا مدير برنامج
افريقيا في معهد تشاتا ماوس من لندن شكرا
لك
قام وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيليه اتمار
بن غفير بجوله في حي الطور بمدينه القدس
تحت حراسه امنيه من قوه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي
وافاد شهود عيان بان الوزير الاسرائيلي
نفذ جولات استفزازيه في شوارع الحي بحمايه
مشدده
وتزامن ذلك مع قيام مستوطنين بتجول في
ازقه البلده القديمه في القدس المحتله حيث
قاموا بالرقص والغناء بطريقه استفزازيه
في ملف الاسرى طلب مجلس الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي من الحكومه عدم التعامل مع
قرار بنافير بتطليص زيارات اهالي الاسرى
الفلسطينيين الى مره كل شهرين بدلا من مره
كل شهر وطلب مجلس الامن القومي ارجاء ذلك
الى ما بعد عقد جلسه خاصه برئاسه رئيس
الحكومه بنيامينه ياهو للبت في الامر
وكانت الاجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه قد
حذرت من تداعيات هذا القرار داخل السجون
وخارجها
من جهتها اكدت لجنه الطوارئ العليا للحركه
الاسيره في فلسطين ان الاسرى في سجون
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مستعدون لاستئناف
معركهما المستمره على قاعده الوحده
الوطنيه لمواجهه اجراءات وزير الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي اتمار
واكدت اللجنه انها ستعلن في بيان مسار
الخطوات وما اتفقت عليه الفصائل مجتمعه في
السجون وافادت هيئه شؤون الاسرى والمحررين
ونادي الاسير الفلسطيني في بيان مشترك ان
الاسرار مستعدون لخوض مواجهه جديده
واعتبرت الهيئه ونادي الاسير اعلان بنافير
قرار حق الاسرى في الزياره
لعبا بالنار التي ستحرق من اشعلها حسب
تعبيرها
ينضم الينا من رام الله الدكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي الامين العام للمبادره الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه دكتور البرغوثي مرحبا بك ما
خطوره هذا القرار
الذي اتخذه بنغفير فيما لو
طبق بالفعل
الخطوره في هذه الاجراءات ليس فقط
الاجراءات التي يسعى هذا الارهاب الفاشي
بن جير لتطبيقها بل حقيقه ان الحكومه
الاسرائيليه هي فعلا حكومه فاشيه بشكل
كامل وهي تشن هجمه على كل الشعب الفلسطيني
اجراءات بنجفير ضد الاسرى والاسيرات هي
جزء من هذه الحمله وهو لا يهدف فقط الى
تقليص الزيارات من زياره وكل شهر الى
زياره زياره كل شهرين بل يريد ان ينفذ
خطوات عديده اخرى ومنها حرمان الاسرى من
الطعام والغذاء منها تقليص ساحات او مساحه
الفسحه التي يمكن ان يحصل عليها بين
الزنازين ومنها ايضا ان يرفض الاعتراف
بالممثلي المعتقلين والاسرى في سجون
الاحتلال ومنها انه يسعى لكي يتحكم في
حياتهم من كل ناحيه يريد ان يجعلها حياتهم
عذابا كما قال وان يجعلهم يقاسوا الامرين
وبالتالي نعم بالنار وهو سيفشل لانه
الحركه الاسيره ستصمت في وجهه وستقاوم هذه
الاجراءات وستفشل هذه الاجراءات كما فعلت
سابقا رفض رئاسه الوزراء لهذا القرار
وتحذير الاجهزه الامنيه هل هو نابع من
معرفه بالتداعيات ام في اطار
التجاذب على القرار والصلاحيات داخل
الحكومه
لا المساله مساله ان هؤلاء الذين لديهم
خبره سابقه وليسوا مستجدين في الصوره مثل
بنجرير يعرفون تماما ما معنى هذه
الاجراءات وما الذي ستؤدي اليه هي ستؤدي
الى اضراب شامل عام في كل السجون من قبل
خمسه الاف اسير واسير
وستؤدي الى انفجار في كل الضفه الغربيه
وقطاع غزه والمنطقه باسرها الشعب
الفلسطيني باسره سيهب دفاعا عن الاسرى وعن
حياتهم وعن حقوقهم وستشهد المنطقه انفجارا
شاملا اذا كان هناك قضيه الى جانب قضيه
المسجد الاقصى يمكن ان تفجر الوضع برمته
فهي قضيه الاسرى والاسيرات في سجون
الاحتلال وبالتالي هؤلاء الاخرين يعرفون
تماما ما هي خطوره ان ينفجر كل هذا الوضع
نتيجه اجراءات
اجراءات بين الفاشيه بنثير يستمر
باجراءاته وايضا
بزياراته التي يصفها الفلسطينيون
بالاستفزازيه اخيرا في حي الطور في القدس
ما خلفيات هذه الزياره واهدافها والرسائل
من ورائها برايك
ما يحاول ان يفعلوا امرين الامر الاول ان
يكرس الوجود الاستيطاني الاسرائيلي وان
يكرس اجراءات القمع ضد الفلسطينيين هو لم
يكن فقط في حي الطور اليوم وانما كان قبل
ذلك في النقب
ليشاهد ويتابع ويحضر عمليات هدم بيوت
الفلسطينيين في الداخل في اراضي النقب هذا
الرجل استفزازي وله هدفان الهدف الاول الى
جانب سموتريدج هو تعميق الخطه الوحيده
التي لديهم وهي تهويد وضم الضفه الغربيه
بكاملها وممارسه الارهاب ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني ومن ناحيه اخرى هم في تنافس
معنى تنياهو هم يدركون في قراره نفسهم ان
هذه الحكومه لا مستقبل لها ومعرضه
للانهيار واليوم كما سمعتم يعني تل ابيب
كانت في حاله انهيار كامل صدام مع
الارتريين صدام مظاهرات هائله ضد هذه
الحكومه
يحاول ان يكسب لنفسه شعبيه زائفه عبر هذه
الاجراءات وهذا التطرف العنصري ولكن في
نهايه المطاف هذه ايضا حكومه نتنياهو وهذه
الفاشيه هي فاشيه الحركه الصهيونيه
العنصريه المتطرفه التي ينسجم فيها كل
هؤلاء المتطرفون معا شكرا للدكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي الامين العام للمبادره الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه احدثتنا من رام الله
اعلنت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه اصابه 170
شخصا على الاقل في مواجهات بين الشرطه
الاسرائيليه
ومتظاهرين من طالبين اللجوء في تل ابيب
هذا وقال مراسل الجزيره ان من بين الجرحى
نحوه 30 شرطيا بينما اعلن قائد شرطه تل
ابيب ان الاشتباكات باتت تحت السيطره
وكانت تعمل شغب قد اندلعت بين مؤيدين
ومعارضين اريتيريين يقيمون في تل ابيب على
خلفيه مهرجان
نظمته سفاره بلادهم في المدينه
هذا وقال مكتب رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي ان
بنيامينه ياهو قرر تشكيل فريق خاص لدراسه
اتخاذ اجراءات ضد المتسللين غير الشرعيين
الذين شاركوا في اعمال الشغب بما في ذلك
اجراءات الترحيل على خلفيه ما وصفها
باعمال شغب الخطيره التي وقعت في تل ابيب
ينضم الينا من ام الفحم الدكتور مهند
مصطفى مدير مركز مدى الكرمل للدراسات
والخبير في الشؤون الاسرائيليه مرحبا بك
سيد مهند
عن ماذا يعبر اولا هذا المشهد الذي
انتشر في شوارع تل ابيب وتلك الاشتباكات
بين الشرطه الاسرائيليه
والاريتيريين المعارضين والمؤيدين
لحكومه بلادهم
يعني هو يعبر عن مشهدين المشهد الاول هو
طبعا النقاش السياسي في داخل اريتيريا
نفسها حول النظام السياسي بين المعارضين
وبين المؤيدين النظام وكان واضح انه اغلب
المتظاهرين هم كانوا معايدين للنظام الذين
حاولوا ان يوقفوا ويمنعوا اقامه مهرجان في
السفاره الامريكيه دائما النظام ولكن ايضا
من الجهه الثانيه وهذا الامر المهم انه
يعبر عن غضب الجاليه من السياسات
الاسرائيليه يعني هنالك في اسرائيل هنالك
حوالي 24000 ولكن اسرائيل منذ عام 2018 لم
تعترف بمكانه لاجئ الا ل 38 فرد منهم وهذا
يدل ان اسرائيل تتخذ سياسات هجره جدا
يمينيه متطرفه اتجاه طالبيه اللجوء من من
الدول الاخرى وايضا ذلك حتى يتم اتعلق
باللاجئين الاوكرانيين الذين جاءوا الى
اسرائيل وايضا هنالك في الكثير من العقبات
التي تفرضها اسرائيل على منح مكانه لاجئ
لطالبي اللجوء في اسرائيل وذلك هذا
الاحتجاج فيه احتجاج داخلي ضد السياسات
الاسرائيليه اتجاه المهاجرين اتجاه طالبين
اللجوء وهذه السياسات الصارمه الاسرائيليه
التي تمنع منح مكانه لاجئ من اجل الحفاظ
تحت مسمى الحفاظ على اسرائيل كدوله يهوديه
ولكن ايضا
نعم ولكن ايضا ماذا
لا ولكن ايضا يعني هذا ايضا يدل انه
اسرائيل يعني ارادت من هذا المشهد ان
تستغله يعني اليمين الاسرائيلي منذ اكثر
من 10 سنوات يحاول ان يطرد كل طالب اللجوء
وكل المهاجرين الذين جاؤوا من افريقيا الى
بلادهم وهو وهم يحاولون يستغلوا اي مشهد
واي حدث من اجل ان يبغيوا ويقتل مصداقيه
لذلك هنا يطرح السؤال عن طريقه تعاطي
الشرطه مع هؤلاء هذا العنف الذي شاهدناه
بطريقه تعاطي الشرطه وسقوط ما ما يقارب
140 جريحا ايضا
كيف يمكن ان نفسر هذا المشهد الذي اختلف
كليا عن تعامل الشرطه مع التظاهرات مثلا
التي خرج ضد حكومه نتنياهو
سؤال ممتاز اولا هذا هذا يعبر عن سياسات
الحكومه اليمنيه وبالذات يعبر عن وزير
الامن القومي الذي واحده من توجهاته
السياسيه والايديولوجيه هي معادات
المهاجرين بشكل عام ومعدات المجموعات في
داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي وبالذات المجموعه
الفلسطينيه ولذلك الشرطه تتعامل مع
المهاجرين مع احتجاج المهاجرين ومع
مجموعات الاقليات في داخل اسرائيل بعنف
وبقمع اكثر ما تتعامل مع جماهير ومع
مجموعات اخرى في داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي
ولكن يجب ان نضم الى ذلك ان اليمين
الاسرائيلي الذي يعبر عنه واحده من خطاب
السياسي هي معاداه المهاجرين الذين يسكنون
بالذات في تل ابيب الذين يسكنون في جنوب
تل ابيب في الاحياء الفقيره في داخل
الجنوط الاديب ولذلك الشرطه تعبرت عمليا
في قمعها لهذا الاحتجاج تعبيرا عن
السياسات اليمنيه المعاديه للمهاجين هنالك
اليمين منذ عشر سنوات يحاول ان يشرع وان
يتخذ ممارسات من اجل طرد هؤلاء المهاجرين
سواء طالبين اللجوء او من دخلوا الى
اسرائيل بطرق غير قانونيه ولكن يعيشون منذ
عشرات السنوات في داخل اسرائيل يعني يا
هنالك في اسرائيل اكثر اكثر من 15 عاما
وحتى هذه اللحظه لم تقم السياسات
الاسرائيليه بتنظيم مكانتهم واقامتهم في
داخل الصيد وذلك هذا القمع الزائد لهذا
الاحتجاج يعبر عن السياسات اليمنيه في
داخل اسرائيل المعاديه لكل يهودي دكتور
مهند مصطفى مدير مركز مدى الكرمل للدراسات
والخدير في الشؤون الاسرائيليه شكرا لك
ذكرت مصادر سوريه محليه ان الاهالي في مدن
وبلدات هاجين وغرانيج والبغوز بريف دير
الزور اعلنوا تشكيل مجالس مدنيه لاداره
شؤون المدينه بعد سيطره مقاتلي العشائر
العربيه عليها وانسحاب ما تعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه واندلعت اشتباكاتهم في
الساعات الماضيه ببلده الكبر في ريف دير
الزور الغربي مع استمرار المواجهات في
مدينه البصيره وجبل البصيره وفي منبج بريف
حلب وقالت المصادر ان مقاتلي لعشائر
سيطروا على قرى عرب كبير والمحموديه
رجال موته حمر تنحسر شيئا فشيئا سيطره ما
تعرف بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه في محافظه
دير الزور لصالح مقاتلي العشائر العربيه
ذلك قتال تتوسع فيه سيطره العشائر على
بلدات مهمه بالريف الغربي لدير الزور يعلن
الاهالي في تلك القرى تشكيل مجالسا مدنيه
لاداره شؤونهم المحليه بينما يتواصل
القتال في مدينه البصيره وجبل البصيره
الذي تتحصن فيهما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه تقول مصادر ان هذه القوات
استقدمت تعزيزات عسكريه الى ريف دير الزور
تلك محافظه تشكل 18% من مساحه سوريا
ويقسمها نهر الفرات تنقسم معه السيطره ما
بين ما تسمى قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
والنظام السوري تقود تحالف ما يعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه وحدات حمايه الشعب
الكردي بالاضافه الى احزاب وتشكيلات
عسكريه كرديه وعربيه ابرزها مجلس دير
الزور العسك الممثل الاساسي للعشائر
العربيه في المنطقه قاتلت هذه التشكيلات
موحده تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه قبل عده
اعوام بدعم امريكي بعد ان انتهت الحرب مع
تنظيم الدوله واخرج من المحافظه الغنيه
بالنفط طفت الى السطح الخلافات الداخليه
تملمت الاطراف من بعضها لسنوات لكنها وصلت
نقطه الانفجار قبل اسبوع يتوسعوا مجلس دير
الزور العسكري ويطالب ببسط سيطرته بشكل
اوضح على المناطق ذات الغالبيه العربيه في
دير الزور يتوسع نفوذه الاداري والمادي
والعسكري لكن دون صدام حتى اعتقلت ما تعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه قاده المجلس
بتهمه ارتكاب مخالفات جنائيه
اندلعت المواجهات واتسع الدائره
الاشتباكات من دير الزور الى الحسكه وحلب
وسيطر مقاتلوا العشائر على مدن وبلدات عده
كانت تحت سيطره ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه ولا يزال القتال مستمرا تعرب
واشنطن عن قلقها من صراع نشب بين حلفائها
في المنطقه الحدوديه مع العراق وتحث
الخارجيه الامريكيه على ضبط النفس وتخشى
من استغلال ايراني روسي للاحداث تراقب
تركيا وتتهم ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه بارهاب معارضيها في المجمل
تلتزم الاطراف الخارجيه الصمت او تعلن
متابعتها لما يجري حتى الان
ضمن سلسله نظره من التخوم تبث الجزيره
تقرير خاصه بالعلاقات التاريخيه بين روسيا
وبعض الدول الاوروبيه المطله على ما يدين
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا او المجاوره
نجول في العديد من المدن الاوروبيه لتسليط
الضوء على جذور العداء وفرص السلام
المهدوره بين موسكو وبعض العواصم الغربيه
البدايه من فنلندا التي عرفت الاحتلال
السوفيتي وخاضت الحروب مع موسكو وحافظت مع
ذلك على حيدها الى ان بدات روسيا حربها
على اوكرانيا الى تقرير الزميل جمال
العرضاوي من العاصمه الفنلنديه هيلسنكي
هيلسنكي عاصمه السعاده يقال انها تسكن هنا
منذ سنوات ولا احد يعرف سر خلطتها
الفنلنديه هناك الاقتصاد القوي
والديمقراطيه الثابته وهناك من لا يستبعد
سياسه الحياد من هذه الكيمياء
يبدو ان الكل سعيد هنا حتى هذا الدب هل
انت دب الروسي لابد انه يؤكد انتمائه
لفنلندا كان قدماء الفنلنديين يقدسون الدب
وينظرون اليه بوافر الاحترام المشروب
بالرهبه لدرجه ان اسمه كان يهمسا
نافكك لفنلندا من الجوار الروسي ولا مجال
لنسيان الجور الامبراطوري قرن ونيف من
الاحتلال هذا تمثال للقيصر الروسي الكسندر
الثاني في قلب هيلسنكي وهذه مدافع روسيه
في جزيره سومن لينا الفنلنديه يقال ان
زعيم البلاشر لم يمانع في استقلال فنلندا
ولكن حربا دارت بين جيشين فنلنديين ابيض
واحمر على غرار ما حصل في روسيا البلشيريه
انتصر الحمر في روسيا وفاز البيض في
فنلندا ولكن ذلك لم يفسد للجيره وده الى
ان راى يوسف ستالين غير ذلك
سنه 39 و900 والف شنت موسكو حربا على
فنلندا وهذه الحرب تقدم نسخه استباقيه
قديمه عن حرب اوكرانيا الجاريه الان
كان الهدف تغيير الحدود من اجل الامن ايضا
لم يسمي حربه على فنلندا حربا بل حمله
تماما كما فعل بوتين الذي يعاقب كل من لا
يسمي الحرب على اوكرانيا عمليه خاصه
كلاحقتها عرفت هذه الحرب هبه من الدول
الاوروبيه لنجده فنلندا ولكنها انتهت بعد
حوالي عامين بصلح رعاه الاوروبيون انفسهم
ويقال فرضوه على فنلندا على الرغم من انهم
انتهى بقظم اكثر من عشر مساحه فنلندا
لصالح الجار السوفيتي من يدري باي صلح
ستنتهي الحرب على اوكرانيا وما هو حجم
قضمه بالمقارنه مع يوسف سلفه
هناك شخصيه فنلنديه رائده ميزت العلاقات
المتداخله بين فنلندا وروسيا المارشال
كارل غوستاف مانر هايم
بدا حياته العسكريه في جيش الخياله
القيصري الروسي عندما كانت فنلندا محميه
روسيه وتردد الى الصين واليابان في مهمات
خاصه للاستخبارات الروسيه قدم تقارير
وافيه على مهمته ولكنه تحول بعد الثوره
البولسريه الى عدو لدود للاتحاد السوفيتي
تحالف مع هتلر ثم عاد واعلن عليه العصيان
اصبح الرجل رئيسا لفنلندا بعد الحرب ومات
وهو بطل من اجل استقلالها
شهد هذا البيت الفنلندي اهم محاوله لتطويق
الحرب البارده هنا اجتمع سنه 75 و900 قاده
35 دوله بما في ذلك وزيرا الخارجيه
غراميكو
رفقه زعيميهما بريج
للبحث في اسس التعايش بين المعسكرين شهدت
فنلندا لقاءات عديده وقد كان فيها ما يبشر
قد يكون من الرمزي ان تتزامن التصليحات في
بيت فنلندا مع التحاقها بالحلف الاطلسي من
يدري ماذا سترمم فنلندا وهي عضوا بهذا
الحلف
بين دبين كبير وصغير امتدت جبهه جديده
طويله تذكر فنلنديون الاحتلال الروسي
والغزو السوفيتي وتذكر الاعلام الروسي ما
يسميه النازيه الفنلنديه المنسيه هناك من
يرى في كل هذا اكبر خسارات بوتين الذي
اراد ان يدفع الاطلسيه عن اوكرانيا شرقا
فجاءه الاطلسي شمالا سقط الحياد في فنلندا
وبدا الباب التركي العالي برفع اخر
الحواجز في وجه السويد للالتحاق بالاطلسي
مما يزيد من عزله روسيا التي ستجد نفسها
الدوله الوحيده الخارجه عن الحلف من مجمل
الدول المتشاطئه على بحر البلطيق ولتجد
نفسها مره اخرى الدوله الوحيده المحاصره
من قبل دول الاطلسي في كامل منطقه المتجمد
الشمالي
يعرف عن بوتين انه لم يخسر حروبه لحد الان
ولكن فنلندا هي اولى خسارات بوت دونما حرب
على الحدود بين البلدين فهل يكون السر في
هزيمه بوتين هو عدم جره الى حرب مباشره
فنلندا خبرت الحروب مع روسيا وهناك من
ينتظر ان تلعب دورا متميزا داخل الحلف
الاطلسي باتجاه عقلانه العلاقات من اجل
الحفاظ على العالم في المقابل ماذا ستربح
فنلندا منخراطها في الحلف الاطلسي اذا
كانت قد ربحت كل شيء وهي خارجه ام ان حرب
روسيا الحاليه على اوكرانيا لم تترك اي
مجالا لتفوت شغف امتطاء الثور الاطلسي
الهارب باوروبا
ارض الصيادين ارض الغابات منذ القديم وهذا
الشعب يحتطب لدفء غده متخذا من الصوم
الفنلنديه صوره للطمانينه في ثلج الشمال
تربع خلال عقود ما بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه على عرش الصناعات الالكترونيه
الحديثه جوالا على شبكات التواصل فهل
ستستمر هناءته في ظل قواعد التحالف
الجديده اراد بوتين ان يبعثر الاوراق ولكن
الغرب اعاد خلطها ويريد تركيبها ولعل
الحسم متروك لمن سيعرف اين ومتى وكيف يقطع
الطريق على عدوه والطرفان لا يعدمان
الوسائل من التنازلات الموجعه الى زر
النووي المريع
غريبه متناقضه هي علاقه روسيا لفنلندا
يحكمها ثالث الحدود والحرب والسلام وهناك
في فنلندا سلمان سلم للسعاده ارتقت فيه
هيلسنكي اعلى الدرجات وسلم للحياد ترجلت
منه اخيرا ترى كيف سيؤثر هذا النزول في
ذاك الصعود ام انهما سلمان متوازيان جمال
العرضاوي الجزيره هل سانكي فنلندا
قبل ايام قليله كشفت كاسل هيكس نائبه وزير
الدفاع الامريكي عن خطه ستنافذها الولايات
المتحده على مدار عامين لنشر الاف مسيرات
لمواجهه ما تعتقد واشنطن انه تفوق عسكري
صيني هذا تفوق مبني على العديد التقليدي
للجنود والمعدات وحسب ما قالت هيكس فان
واشنطن تبحث عن كسر معادله التنافس الكمي
هذه فكيف سيكون ذلك
كلمه السر هي الذكاء الاصطناعي حيث اعلنت
هيكس اطلاق برنامج النسخ المتماثل
الذي سيستغل المنصات الصغيره والذكيه
والاقل تكلفه والوفيره
اليوم كتب الادمره المتقاعد في البحريه
الامريكيه جيمس
ستافريدس كتب مقالا جاء فيه ان جزءا من
الفكره الامريكيه يعتمد على تجميع اسراب
ضخمه من مركبات صغيره ذاتيه التحكم بسرعه
وارسالها الى الميدان ودمجها في القتال
مشيرا الى ان ما تفعلها القوات الاوكرانيه
في ساحه المعركه اليوم قريب من هذه الفكره
بشكل مبسط
حصيله كل ما سبق بحسب الادمره المتقاعد هي
جيوش اقل عددا وتكلفه واكثر ذكاء وفعاليه
وسرعه
اذا
الارقام والتكاليف هي من الدوافع المهمه
للتحولات امريكيه وعالميا
مشروع التحول العسكري قد يكلف عشرات
المليارات هو مبلغ لا يذكر امام ميزانيه
عسكريه للبنتاجون مقدارها 850 مليار دولار
الجانب الاخر يكمن في العنصر البشري الذي
سيقل حضوره في ساحه المعركه مقابل دور
يتركز في الاشراف هو تامين الاتصالات حيث
ان الذكاء الاصطناعي سيكون له دور كبير في
تقدير المهمه القتاليه طبعا وفقا مدخلات
اساسيه
للحديث عن هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
مونتانا الادميرال ويليام فالون القائد
السابق للمنطقه الامريكيه العسكريه الوسطى
والقائد السابق للاسطول الامريكيه الثاني
في المحيط الاطلسي سيد فالون مرحبا بك
يعني بناء على ما تقدم نسال
عن شكل الحرب المستقبليه بين الجيوش كيف
ستكون هذه الحروب
اعتقد بالاعتماد على المواضيع حول
المسيرات ما نراه ما اسميه هو تطور منطقي
فيما يتعلق بتغيير التكنولوجيات واقتباس
وتبني التكرار الجهات الجديده التوقع انه
سيوفر امكانيات اكثر كفاءه
وقدرات
لقدرات قتاليه
اقوى واعتقد ان الخبره والتي التقيناها من
حرب اوكرانيا كانت بناءها وكانت متصاعده
ومتزايده في مقارنه ببقيه دول العالم وهو
امرنا سينتشر باعتقادي بالتالي الامر ليس
مفاجئا على الاطلاق فيما يتعلق ما عدا
سرعه سرعه تبني هذه التكنولوجيا الجديده
وهذا شيء يجب ان يثير الانتباه حقا انت
انت هنا تركز على موضوع المسيرات على
اهميه هذا الموضوع لكن هناك ايضا جانب اخر
مرتبط
بالمسيرات التي
يسيرها الذكاء الاصطناعي والاسلحه ايضا
التي تعتمد على الذكاء الاصطناعي
اريد ان اذكر المشاهدين ان هنالك واقع هنا
هنالك الكثير من التوقعات حول ذكاء
الاصطناعي لكن في البدايه في بدايه فان
البشر عليهم ان يقوموا ببرمجه
اللوغاريتمات من اجل تمكين هذه الالات
والمعدات من اجل القيام بمهامها التي صممت
لها بالتالي فكره انها ستسير بشكل
اوتوماتيكي وانه ليس هنالك اي تدخل مع
الجهد البشري هو امر غير دقيق قد يكون هنا
ربما في مساله استخدام الانظمه سواء كانت
انظمه اسلحه او انظمه
مراقبه او استطلاع ان يكون ان تكون لكي
تكون قادره على الاداء يجب ان يتم توجيهها
وبرمجتها عند في فتره التصميم ويجب ان
يكون هنا عنصر بشري مشارك اعتقد علينا ان
نتذكر هذا الامر الشيء الاخر انه والذي
يجب ان ننتظر لنراها انه
مدى الاستقلاليه ربما
اليه التشغيل عندما نرى نرى استخدام
الكثير من هذه
المعدات والالات هنالك عنصر بشري فعال في
مرحله ما من عمل هذه الاسلحه او الانظمه
بالتالي لا ارى اي شيء قد يظهر خلال
المستقبل القريب قد يغير هذا الواقع ربما
يجب ان يكون هنالك نوع من التداخل البشري
مع هذه الانظمه في مراحل متعدده ربما هذا
في المستقبل القريب لكن بالنظر الى التطور
السريع للذكاء الاصطناعي
يعني لا يمكن الوصول الى مرحله لا يكون
هناك تدخل بشري مباشر انما فقط في يعني في
وضع المعلومات او في تلقيم المعلومات لا
اكثر ولا اقل وتبقى المهمه بالكامل على
الالات
بتسيير من الصناعي
هذا ممكن لكن اعتقد انه سنراه ان القياده
وخاصه القياده السياسيه تريد ان يكون لها
راي معين فيما سيحصل فكره ان يكون
هنالك
اداء ربما اوتوماتيكي سيتم الضغط على زر
ويحصل كل شيء بدون اي تدخل بشري لا اعتقد
انه من المحتمل ان يحصل اعتقد ان الاداره
السياسيه ستريد ان تكون منخرطه بشكل من
الاشكال في تقرير مثلا تحديد الهدف
والاسباب التي دعتها لاختيار هذا الهدف
واين ومتى سيتم استهدافه لكن كما قلت فان
يكون هنالك تشغيل هذه الانظمه بشكل
مستقل تماما بدون اي تدخل امر غير دقيق
ولا نريد هذا الامر اصلا الادمره ويليام
فالون القائد السابق للمنطقه الامريكيه
العسكريه الوسطى والقائد السابق للوصول
الامريكيه الثاني في المحيط الاطلسي شكرا
جزيلا لك
بهذا مشاهدينا نصل الى نهايه الحصاد لهذه
الليله تصبحون على
خير